the simple truth that we all know
we all know is that if you take away
guns first off there are probably 400
million guns something like that what's
the number i think it's around 350
million if i'm not mistaken guns in the
united states right now and it's an
estimate because they don't fully know
but there basically are as many guns as
people something like that in the united
states right now um if you say okay
we're gonna take away a hundred million
guns and we're gonna make it harder for
18 year olds to get guns etc etc uh what
will happen is that bad guys will be the
only people to have guns there are
393.3 million guns in the united states
right now there are an awful lot of new
gun owners in the united states over the
last two years ourselves included
because we realized especially living in
los angeles we could not depend on the
defunded police and the ridiculous
district attorneys to defend us as riots
literally went by our house so the point
is that you could take away guns from
people and who will give up guns who who
will do a buy back now they always say a
buyback on guns except a buyback would
be if the same person who sold you the
gun bought it back this is a buyback
when the government is going to give you
money for it doesn't really buy back
that i don't think that's the technical
term on that one but the simple truth is
the more that you say okay we'll get
some of these guns off the streets good
people will give up their guns good guys
who have decided to defend themselves
will give up their guns the bad guys
will still have the guns this is a point
there's a clip going around
twitter right now that's going viral
that joe rogan has been making for quite
some time and i don't think it's wise to
take the guns away from the people and
leave all the power to the government we
see how they are even with an armed
populace they still have
a tendency towards totalitarianism and
the more increased
power and control you have over people
the easier it is for them to do what
they do and there's a natural
inclination when you're a person in
power to try to hold more power and
acquire more power and it's never
there's never an inclination to give
more power back to the people to give
more freedoms back to the people
freedom's loss are rarely regained
how do you stop that no one knows how to
stop that what is the answer is the
answer take everyone's guns well they're
not gonna give their guns up so it's
gonna you're gonna have only criminals
are gonna have guns an interesting line
there uh no one knows how to stop that i
i think there are some ways to stop that
actually we're gonna do a cold close
with thomas soule
from an interview i did with him a
couple years ago where he talks about
how you can stop it and that you can
actually stop the ever encroaching
government you just kind of have to have
the will to do it but who in this if
you've been watching this show from the
beginning it's like who has made sense
in these clips that we've showed you was
it was it joe rogan right there saying
we have a mental health problem not a
gun problem was it jordan peterson
talking about the inch by inch that
they'll come get you
was it ted cruz
saying
that in essence
this is never going to stop that the
elites have it one way and that they
want you to live another way that we
know they don't live as they defund the
police and make sure that your
neighborhoods are more dangerous is it
those people that are making sense or or
did you watch this show and do you think
that justin trudeau made sense as he
made sure as he pushes this through
canadian parliament that the average
person in canada will not be able to buy
or sell a gun and defend their family
or was it was it joy reid who you
thought made sense there who said that
the shooter did not have a mental health
problem there was no mental health issue
with the individual who stole the
futures of 19 children in uvalde texas
or was it chuck schumer who you thought
made sense there who said that the maga
republicans never get enough blood that
they have this endless bloodlust no
amount of bloodshed seems to be enough
for mega republicans it's so obvious if
you if you just calmly try to think
about these things what is going on here
and i think
i think
that if we calmly explain ourselves if
we fight earnestly and honestly that
like most of the issues of the day
we will win but they will not stop they
will not stop it is as simple as that